In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for September 28, on which we commemorate, the holy martyr
Wenceslaus, Prince of the Chex, St. Wenceslaus, or Wenslas, was the grandson of St. Ludmila
commemorated on the 16th of September.
He was equipped with standing his high rank.
He ordered his life by the faith and example of the great ascetics.
He strengthened the orthodox faith of his people and was ever watchful, lest any be unjustly
condemned in his courts.
In his zeal for the faith of Christ, and in his love for his neighbor, Wenceslaus purchased
heathen children who were being sold as slaves, baptize them and provide it for their education
as Christians.
He translated St. John's Gospel into Czech.
He enshrined the relics of St. Vetus and of St. Ludmila in Prague.
St. Wenceslaus was assassinated while the guest of his brother, Bulislov, as soon as he
seized power, Bulislov invited clergy from Germany to Bohemia, and the Latin service
became the rule in the churches.
St. Wenceslaus died in the year 929, his holy relics lie in the church of St. Vetus in Prague.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.